he's my buddy dick vitale how are you
dickie v
i'm doing really great rich you know
really exciting time
last night i ran into you we're down
here at uh
uh beverly hills right there at the
beautiful
delhi
that was fantastic hey uh what a time to
be a
uh tampa sports fan dick this is it
right this is
this is this it really is i i'd say it's
a great great moment here for this area
we got the lightning winning that
stanley cup we got the rays right now in
the world series
and we got the bucks i'm telling you
guys out there at football land you
better not
you better not doubt this club if they
get healthy the problem has been
they haven't had their full cast and
mike evans hasn't been mike evans yet
because he's got an ankle problem
while fournette hasn't played the last
two games he's a power back
the game prior to getting injured he had
100 some yards
did a great job in the power to combine
with the kid jones has really improved
uh godwin's been out for like two three
games he played the last game
i'm gonna tell you and tom brady is like
a 25 year old and he's such a fierce
competitor
i'm telling you rich if they're healthy
with that defense
they can win the super bowl there's no
doubt about that
there's no doubt about that and you're
you know the the
city of los angeles can add a world
series title to an nba championship
and uh tampa can add a world series
title to a stanley cup
um so you know when you think about that
though the market's a little different
aren't they
talking about tampa bay tampa bay is
going to be title town
yes usa we're going to go three for
three i feel it
i feel it i swear to god i went to the
vbdi
my white town ball dome index
how good he is we're going to hear about
bellinger being clutch
we're going to hear about the superstar
mookie bats we're going to hear all of
that the vegas
people out there they got the dodgers
the favorite but you know what
there's a couple teams sitting home that
was supposed to win too i heard in game
five oh
they got a face jared cole the 320
million dollar man
are you kidding they got standing back
now they got judge back
this is the yankees everybody expected
ray's have no shot
excuse me excuse me i think the yankees
are sitting home watching on tv tonight
then i heard it from the astros oh the
astros won three in a row
momentum has switched rays have no
chance in game
seven you get in their astros have been
there with correa and
certainly with altuve and bregman and
bradley
they've been there springer and the race
have no
shot in game seven excuse me i think the
astros are watching on tv
and you know the dodgers three out of
four years rich three out of four years
they've been in the championship and i
said on sportscenter a little bit
earlier
i taped a speech to the team but
basically it was about and i said you
know
the dodgers took strike one first time
in a world series in the three of the
last four years
they took the fastball they took the
curveball the second time
they're going to take the slider for the
third dive because the rays are going to
win in seven
does anybody throw a slider on the race
i thought they'd only throw 90 million
miles an hour dick
that's a good question i should have
went to that's right
because that's what the rays do hey i
follow you on twitter dick even
i'm all fired up man i know i'm 81 and
i'm actually about 12. i know i love it
i follow you on twitter at dickyv and
you were like the rest of america
wondering why in the heck
are they taking charlie morton out game
seven
when they're taking him no i can't
believe that but they've got us
they've got they've got it they've got a
plan
this is what they do though pushing all
the right buttons basically
right he's got to be clearly the manager
of the year i mean obviously the dodge
is going to be a tough tough tough
situation right but you know the bottom
line is what's great about it
and it's ironic we have the best team
all year in the national league
and we're the best team all year in the
american league playing for
the world championship i think that's
super i know very sad part this can't be
there you know
the razor i talked to the president and
president would have liked me to come
out there but
i got to be careful with that cloven 19.
i just can't take a chance
getting on those kind of people who's
gone for me that hit me uh
i'd be in big trouble of course dick you
got to be careful
you're a national treasure you stay put
right there and you go you keep doing
what you're doing so
did you say did you again uh your your
speeches
uh are legendary anybody who's ever seen
you deliver a soliloquy uh trying to
move somebody when it comes obviously to
your charitable work it's
it's amazing there's nothing like it so
you did you you gave a vital special to
the team you taped one
for the race yeah well well i'm not
really yes being called me up today they
said
if we could have you do a sports center
uh like you were going to speak to the
team
what would you say and i did a speech
that i just got here on sportscenter
okay but uh
i look forward to it i just love being
with people as you know rich
people know me i just love being with
people and i've always tried to look at
things in life
a little bit optimistic i mean we got a
serious problem going on here with
covent 19
because people want to follow the advice
of all the experts and
you know it's just running rapid and
it's sad because our priorities got to
be
the health of everyone and the other
thing that really you know i learned as
a kid and it's so important
i think in life my mom and dad
uneducated
taught me in the life they said when i
was a kid growing up
richie was never dick richie treat
people like you want to be treated
respect people and i've tried to do that
all my life and if we all
did that we wouldn't have this division
that we have
there's so much hate in our nation we
need more love man
we need hugs for one another it's simple
just treat people how you want to be
treated
no i know dick and and the beautiful
thing about sports
being as active as it is it is is you
know the
the stories that we see and the good
feel-good stories that you can root for
uh might substitute for for what you're
talking about with a
and a divided nation as you're as you're
pointing out that we could all maybe
come together and watch a sporting event
and root for the for the teams that that
that you want to root for
and your you know your rays clearly have
something to root for they're new
there's a lot of players that uh have
come a long way this
rosa reina kid i mean i don't i don't
think he's got a cold zone
anywhere that he's a walking hot zone
this kid
on youtube you know randy dandy tandy
randy i mean what a story that is
i read dusty baker's quote he couldn't
believe the cardinals gave him up and
actually
i did a tweet the other day i said i
want to thank you in terms of the
cardinals and maybe
i'm going to be on an espn station in st
louis later
and the bottom line is there a big thank
you we should give a christmas gift
i mean are you kidding me how did he
give that up same with nick
anderson we got the marlins the guy was
unhittable
all year he struggled a little bit in
the playoffs but on all year he's been
unhittable
and we get these guys our people that do
an analysis for the players doing a
phenomenal job i mean
you've got to realize this which the
payroll is a joke compared to the other
teams i think we're 27
at about you know it was 162 game season
to be like 70 million
to like the 200 million you talk about
the yankees the dodgers
and it's amazing what they do they they
get talent they play together
there's great camaraderie great
chemistry and they're good players i
mean let's face it they are
good players and we got a kid in the
middle east i was hoping they activated
him for the
playoffs but they did not his name is
wanda franco and everybody i ran the two
scouts rich
i was having uh dinner one night down
here where i live
and these two guys are in town to look
at some players and they came over and
said introduce themselves and they said
we know you're a big baseball fan so i
said well join me
so they joined me and i said let me tell
you something you know those great young
guys you're hearing about tatis
and soto and all these great players in
1920 he said you guys gotta die in the
middle east better than all of it
he's the best so remember this name
wander franco
switch hitter i don't know why he
wouldn't bring him up but somebody told
me it's because they didn't want to
start the clock on the contract
uh anyway they do a great job with the
talent i've been a 21 year old johnny
come lately
21 years of that season tickets first
roll next to the dugout
of the visiting teams talk to all the
players i want their autographs every
just think they handed me baseballs
signings baseball where's dick eva wait
a minute something's wrong here i want
your
autograph and you're a picture you know
it's just so much fun and
and i enjoyed it big time and it sat in
a way that
last we won 96 games we're getting eight
nine thousand fans
yeah i i hear your dick uh before i let
you go tell me about your book
cause let's try and raise as much money
as always your proceeds go to
fighting childhood cancer the lost
season to look at what the journey of
the
2020 national championship could
have been as we all know the pandemic uh
broke just as march madness was about to
tip off i give you the floor on this
well thanks a lot rich i really
appreciate that because it means so much
to me
i've gotten to know so many beautiful
kids over the years and their families
i've spoken several funerals
you know i do a lot of speaking as you
said motivationally across this country
and they were the toughest speeches i
ever had to give in my life i told my
wife when i got out of here
i said i was like nervous rick giving a
speech what do you say of mom and dad
putting a child to rest
my new book the lost season is all about
what could have been
and maybe would have been if we had a
march madness
and most of all the book is getting a
lot of good reviews
but the real great story with it as i
feel is every sale if people
buy it at dickfighter.com nickritel.com
if they get the book there they can get
watercraft copies they could have me
right the dodgers are awesome maybe they
could ever write la's the best
whatever they want i signed it and every
dollar that i would make
every dollar that's 60 cents every
dollar will go to the v foundation for
kids battling cancer
so that's the dickbytel.com and the book
is the lost
season and so um you you basically have
brackets
how far did you have my wolverines yeah
i finished it up with a
how he did the research it was a lot of
fun it was it was almost like therapy
for me
and we finished the last chapter with it
with a complete bracket
and we have all the match-ups and we not
only have the match-ups and who's going
to win
we tell them white is going to why
they're going to win or why they're
going to lose who's going to score who's
not going to score
how many points they're going to get
cetera and we go right down to the
championship game
we go to the final four i'm gonna sweet
sixteen the final end
final four and then to the final two and
the ultimate winner
and it's really just a lot of fun to do
dicky v
love you love you man i love you man you
did a great job richard
i wish you were the city spot again but
you know i couldn't understand
dollars gotta count sometimes
but you've done a great job and really
so you've always treated me with
respect i appreciate that man
older rich you know 81 years old now and
the clock keeps going i'm in the last
last chapter
but i want to make it the best i feel is
enthusiastic as energetic as i've ever
felt in my life i really do
i play singles this morning tennis i
play these young ladies who like in
their 30s and 40s
and i don't play the guys because i
still go play the guys and all i want to
do is talk about hey what about carolina
who could be good this year what about
duke what about
so i finally told people at the country
club and say hey just get me people that
don't follow sports i had a woman ask me
about like three weeks ago i played said
hey
are you retired what do you do for a
living i said well i work in television
i still work you all really
i loved it i loved that that's fantastic
dick at
dickie v on twitter uh i love watching
you live and die with your raise and
at dick evie underscore espn on
instagram and again
go to dickvitel.com to order that book
today
uh to go uh raise as much money as
possible
thank you dick really appreciate it
thanks a lot rich you do
rich ross my man rich mitch eisen is
awesome baby with a cap delay
but today the races are going to be
awesome baby it should be sadness and
tinseltown
you're the best take care of yourself
dick enjoy it
thank you buddy you guys dick vital hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that
watch more right here